okay let's talk about a couple of other
happenings over the weekend that are
horrifying and disgusting radical
republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green has filed articles of impeachment
against Joe Biden and of course they're
going nowhere and we don't really care
other than there is a really important
thing that's going on here there's a
reason that she's doing this and the
reason is that it's helping her to raise
money and if you need proof of that just
see how excited this crowd gets when she
says I filed articles of impeachment
against Joe Biden the crowd seemingly
not caring not knowing not understanding
that the Articles will go nowhere this
is an event I don't even know where this
took place it sort of doesn't matter
it's Bonkers regardless of where it
happened but what we do know is that
Marjorie Taylor green on Friday
introduced three articles of impeachment
against Joe Biden they are meaningless
they will go nowhere but that's what
she's talking about in this clip take a
look and just look if you're listening
listen to how the crowd go goes nuts if
you're watching look at how the crowd
gives her a standing ovation is if this
is you know they're they're acting like
she's cured cancer or something like
that take a look
[Applause]
and I did that on behalf of the American
people that's not those are articles of
impeachment for Marjorie Taylor green
those are articles of impeachment for
the United States of America
so completely cult-like how are we I
mean truly how are we in the same
country as these people this the that
crowd seems
almost like another uh it's a it's a
it's certainly a different culture
altogether I mean people overcome with
emotion out of their minds cheering and
standing and clapping and screaming over
something completely meaningless who's
Dumber right I mean who's more pathetic
who's more disconnected from reality the
person who announces it Marjorie Taylor
green or the people who stand up and
cheer and go crazy and donate money to
her because of the announcement which
they believe has some actual meaning I I
would make the case it's maybe the
people who were doing the donations that
are really the wacky people not that
Marjorie Taylor green isn't isn't wacky
the three elements as if it matters as
if you're curious
um the three elements to the impeachment
articles are number one Biden's
withdrawal of Afghanistan which Trump
planned would be a reason to impeach Joe
Biden number two
illegal immigration through the U.S
Mexico border an issue which was
happening under Donald Trump as well and
lastly Joe Biden's eviction moratorium
which is a good thing Marjorie Taylor
green wants Biden impeached because he
extended the eviction moratorium okay a
green statement announcing the
impeachment resolution also refers to
Joe Biden as a pseudo dictator and says
that he quote shredded the Constitution
it declares his government quote
illegitimate because it is quote no
longer serving its citizens this is
actually all about one thing like yes
Marjorie Taylor green is cuckoo for Coco
Puffs she's out of her mind yes there's
no doubt about that but this is about
one thing and that's fundraising and
sadly it helps for fundraise it does
because the people who donate to her
have no idea what's going on uh in this
world in this universe they hear this
stuff and they donate and she did this
in the past and it worked in the past
and she's doing it again now as a brief
aside
one other thing about what I call
dumb standing ovations
Republican California recall
gubernatorial candidate Larry Elder he
got a dumb Standing Ovation for saying
if he becomes the governor of California
he would end vaccine and mask mandates
take a look at this and check out the
crowd I become governor
[Music]
Mr Sir
when I become governor assuming there
are still mandates for vaccines and
mandate for face masks they will be
repealed before I hit my first cup of
tea
yeah so they they almost like making a
big deal out of giving a standing
ovation for meaningless just idiotic or
nonsense stuff
um but it works and it sucks money out
of these people one day after Joe Biden
took office remember Marjorie Taylor
green filed articles of impeachment
already you might be wondering well on
day one how what are you even impeached
for on that day she accused Biden of
abuse of power for allowing his son
Hunter to work for a Ukrainian Energy
company when he was vice president and
even if you believed there was something
there
it's not something Biden did as
president none of it makes sense but
within hours she started sending out
fundraising emails saying look I just
have filed articles of impeachment
donate to me so I can keep doing it and
it worked
completely unable to advance any
legislation
um completely unable to even engage on
policy in a meaningful way I mean what
on what policy is green actually engaged
screaming about mask requirements at the
floor of the house that's it so this is
what they've been reduced to now in all
seriousness
there's a really good chance that if
Republicans do take control of the house
next year they will impeach Biden it
will go nowhere in the Senate but they
want to make Joe Biden impeached so that
it will be just like Trump was impeached
they want to weaken they want to devalue
impeachment in total by just impeaching
Biden for nothing they will say well
Nancy Pelosi started it when she
impeached Trump over nothing the
difference is there were grounds to
impeach Trump bartering with a foreign
nation and using military aid as
blackmail to get them to make negative
statements about Joe Biden okay Biden
pulled out of Afghanistan it was chaotic
it would have been if Trump pulled out
but it's actually a major accomplishment
to get us out not something you impeach
a president over but they just want to
make impeachment the norm they want to
take control of the house and they want
to impeach Joe Biden to show that Joe
Biden can be an impeached president as
well now just one last thing on that
if they impeach Biden and the Senate
were to convict
um then Kamala Harris is President and
if they impeach Kamala Harris then Nancy
Pelosi is president that would be if
they did it now not if they do it after
taking control of the house
so what exactly is the point of all of
this anyway none of it really makes any
sense it's going to go nowhere but
Marjorie Taylor green is Raising big
bucks on the back of it if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read you
have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or audiobook that you can get
through in just 15 minutes where you're
getting all the key takeaways from the
book just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge by
being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10 different
books in an afternoon obviously it's
perfect for exposing yourself to a new
book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for or you can use it to revisit a book
you've already read or use it to preview
a book before you buy the full version
and read it I recently read A Brief
History of Time Of course course by the
great Stephen Hawking this is a book
that I have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
Pacman I've put the link right
underneath this video